mirror mirror on the wall who's the
fairest of them all
fashionista dog napper the embodiment of
evil
or just misunderstood in disney's
upcoming film cruella we're going back
in time and meeting estella
the woman who came before the infamous
cruella how is glenn close
aka the original cruella involved in the
new film
what secrets will we learn about the
evil legend it's her
it's that devil woman
once upon a time in 1956 a woman named
dodie smith wrote a story called
the 101 dalmatians and so began the
legend of cruella deville
we know that when she was young she was
a mischievous child with black and white
pigtails who was
literally expelled from elementary
school for drinking ink
odd we know but could you expect
anything less from this famed villain
while cruella seems completely made up
the character created by dodie smith was
actually inspired by a famous american
actress
tallulah bankhead though cruella was
meant to be an evil parody of her
five years later the story took to the
screen the shrill voice and distinct
look became known to the world
i know rogers we saw an oddly obsessive
woman whose love for fur drove her to
complete madness
40 years after the book was released
glenn close gave an even more
distinctive face to the name
helping to establish cruella as one of
the most evil disney legends in history
though close wasn't the only memorable
version the classic animated film of
course
as well as appearances in house of mouse
descendants and once upon a time
but who was she before her life of crime
and evil
who is estella well it's cruella before
she was cruel
the upcoming emma stone film isn't going
to be the typical live-action remake
since
it isn't a remake of 101 dalmatians but
rather is diving into the life of
estella and what made her become so
cruel
set in 1970s london estella is a
fashionista ready to become the next
famous designer
it seems like she's made it when she
gets a job working at a fashion house in
london until
reality hits and she understands that
she'll only be cleaning for them
estella knows she has greater potential
and this sense of entitlement is
eventually what leads to her downfall
we also know that she and anita the
owner of the dalmatians
have known each other since they were
children and were even close when
estella went through difficult
circumstances in her life like losing
her father
must be cruella you're dearly devoted
old school mate
so let's be honest not having the job
you want doesn't exactly warrant
becoming a dog napper and engaging in a
life of evil
we don't know if the disney film will
get into it but there is likely a chance
that cruella struggles with some type of
mental illness that was left untreated
some speculations say that she may
suffer from depression bipolar disorder
hello psychotic fits and reckless
driving and histrionic personality
disorder which is the desire to be the
center of attention constantly and is
ultimately damaging to everyone involved
maybe the new film will give us some
insight on her conditions potentially
offering a cautionary tale showing how
damaging mental illness can be if a
person doesn't have the resources or
support they need
while the movie is called cruella maybe
we'll better understand who estella is
learning the story from her point of
view
i live for first i worship first
enough about estella on to cruella
we know her as the villain we love to
hate she's bigger than life and has an
incomparable flair
passionate for high art and fashion
what's not to love honestly
okay well her dog napping ways are
definitely not great
her reasoning for the obsession with the
dalmatians the spots on their fur are
unique and she believes designing
clothes with their fur would bring her
more success and money
yeah we're definitely not fans of that
idea
despite this she's still an extremely
popular character so there are some fans
hoping we won't be presented with
another misunderstood villain
some fans want the cruella we've come to
know and appreciate in our own ways to
remain as she is
pure evil after all she doesn't have
good intentions for those pups
considering the fact that glenn close is
acting as an executive producer on the
film
offers a hint that we might see the
classic cruella in all her evil glory
that combined with a 13 plus rating a
total rarity for a disney movie
the chances of a daring film that has
emma stone tackling that signature
cackle
well let's just say the chances look
pretty good
whether or not she's presented as
misunderstood or pure villain
we're positive stone will bring a
stellar performance to the screen and
remind us all what a wild character
cruella deville is
cruella de vil if she doesn't scare you
no
evil thing will we're definitely
wondering how true these lyrics will
ring after we see the origin story with
the always charming emma stone
whether or not she's presented as good
or bad we can't wait to see this
legendary character brought to life once
again
do you think emma stone will do the role
[Music]
justice